europa möchte sie heute mit uns sprechen
was sie bewegt sie haben einen antrag
gestellt eine strafanzeige gestellt
ja wir haben ein sorgfältiger
vorbereitung eine
umfangreiche strafanzeige gegen die
kriegsverbrecher in der ukraine also die
russischen kriegsverbrecher gestellt und
zwar angefangen von der staatsspitze bis
zu tag auf die kommandoebene das ist
eine ausarbeitung von 130 seiten für den
generalbundesanwalt und in dieser
ausarbeitung sind die einzelnen fälle
stellvertretend dargestellt die wir
kennen mario pohl und
erschließung von vor allen dingen von
zivilen einrichtungen die
zivilbevölkerung anzugreifen ist ein
kriegsverbrecher übrigens haben die
russen auch zwei arbeiten der
reaktorblöcke in der ukraine gezielt
beschossen sich mal vorstellen was es
bedeutet wenn dort radioaktivität
austritt aber wir haben uns konzentriert
auf zwei tatbestände kriegsverbrechen
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit und
diese verbrechen sind gegenstand eines
deutschen rechts das
völkerstrafgesetzbuch sieht das vor seit
2002 und wir wollen jetzt praktische die
waffe des rechts auch einsetzen wir
haben zwar internationalen gericht so
der tätig ist aber wir sind deutsche wir
haben deutsches recht und wir wollen das
jetzt der in den krieg hinein die
signale gesetzt würden werden dass er
den menschen die dort täter werden auch
deutlich macht dass die täter sind und
das bedeutet also dass der
generalbundesanwalt anfangen muss und
das tut er ja auch schon zu ermitteln
beweise zu sammeln
die bekommt davon der flüchtlinge
bekommt er von den nachrichten dieses
bekommt von den engine aus und er
bekommt sie auch von uns wir haben
namenslisten hunderte von land bis auf
die kommandoebene wir wissen also wie
ein buddha verantwortlich war wir wissen
auch dass es ein gezielter angriff war
wie auch andere gezielte angriffe auf
die zivilbevölkerung
geplant sind also keine spontan
reaktion der der soldaten übrigens auch
tschetschenen und die gruppe wagner
steht bei uns das ist eine solche truppe
steht bei uns in der strafanzeige also
alles wir wollen ein signal setzten ihr
kommt nicht davon ihr seid täter und
nichts verjährt und mit dem ziel
einigen die vielleicht sich überlegen ob
sie damit machen und sich für deutlich
zu machen dass sie sich strafbar machen
und zwar in erheblicher weise
kriegsverbrechen lebenslang mitunter je
nachdem und wir haben
völkerstrafgesetzbuch funktioniert der
generalbundesanwalt hat in den letzten
in der letzten zeit syrische täter
angeklagt die von deutschen gerichten
ford hat oben sind also das ist eine
eine möglichkeit in den krieg hinein zu
wirken der uns sehr lange beschäftigen
wird ich warne vor optimismus wir sind
immer wir sind im grunde schon
mittendrin ich möchte mal wissen ob
unsere grenzen unverletzt bleiben ich
möchte mal wissen ob die russen nicht in
georgien oder moldawien wenn weitergehen
denn putin lebt in einer andern welt der
comcom die
vorstellung neuer kämpft gegen eine
gottlose
dekadent unerreicht herold erretten das
was ich wähle und das ist ein religiös
auch untermauert das heißt nützlichkeit
argumente wie wir sie haben pragmatismus
erreicht ihn nicht mehr und ich sagen er
macht weiter alles was wir jetzt hören
mitmachen stellt nichts kommt wir werden
im hohen maße heraus gefordert sein und
wir werden lange auch unserer
gesellschaft damit leben müssen wir
müssen uns darauf einstellen ich habe
immer wieder gesagt wir brauchen eine
chill raider blut schweiß und tränen es
ist vielleicht ein bisschen dramatisch
1941 hat er seinem volk gesagt ich es
kommen düstere zeiten stellt euch darauf
ein und darum dass ein bisschen
abzumildern
das recht in stellung gebracht gegen das
recht des stärkeren
er brauche ich finde es eine ganz
hervorragende
es werde initiative ich glaube wir haben
mit dem völkerstrafgesetzbuch eine
wirklich einzigartige rechts quelle die
kaum ein anderes land hat indem wir eben
auch wirklich außerhalb des territoriums
der rav tat eben täter verurteilen kann
das haben wir gemacht wie sie eben
dargestellt haben und ich find's ganz
wichtig dass wir jetzt an einem
scheidepunkt wo unsere völker
rechtsordnung auf dem prüfstand steht
bleiben wir bei dieser ordnung die wir
uns gemeinsam als welt gemacht haben
sollten nach 19 45 erarbeitet haben
bleiben wir dort geben wir dieser form
auf oder reichen wenn sie auf sie dort
sagen wir schlag mit aller härte zurück
muss klar sein jeder einzelne soldat
wird vor gericht gestellt jeder kommando
wird vor gericht gestellt nach einer
gerechten bestrafung zugeführt also ich
finde sie sind ganz essentieller punkt
auch unserer strategie es muss so sein
ich will nicht soviel sagen ich habe
meine frage herr bauen eigentlich auch
eine informative wenn ich richtig
informiert bin unterscheidet man ja
immer gerne zwischen kriegsverbrechen
immer die individuelle tat verfolgt und
dem genozid der politisch angeordnet
wird was ist das aldi in der ukraine ist
das in hohem kriegsverbrechen oder ist
dass das vernichtung eines volkes also
nein das ist jetzt wenn sie das für
rüstung auf den punkt bringen kommt es
in die nähe eines genozids ist aber
keiner da das muss noch viel intensiver
sein sage ich leider es reicht ja schon
die kriegsverbrechen und den bereichen
gegen die menschlichkeit reichen ja
schon um das ziel zu haben sagt weil sie
bei kriegsverbrechen immer die
individuelle tat so habe ich dabei
gelernt einige straftäter
und das ist natürlich schwierig oder
machen sie das ganze weil sie hoffen
dass sie wenigstens mal kommandeure
wirklich vor den internationalen
strafgerichtshof
dani
möglichkeit auch solche angeordneten
wenn ich
gelernt muss ich den täter haben ja da
haben wir ja
jetzt haben wir den täter dass putin ja
na gut der wird auch sie gerade dem
strafgerichtshof stellen aber wissen sie
bin ich das abschreckt nein dann wären
dann kann ich ja auch zu machen kann ich
sagen weil das ich nicht stellt mache
ich nichts der ist immun als
staatsoberhaupt wissen sie haben mich
nur sowie zwar auch immun und leer und
happy moschee und hinter nein dass das
ist kann nicht das kriterium sagt aus
seiner mannschaft diesen
verbrecherischen sicherheitsrat sind ex
leute nicht immun ja also das also wenn
mit ihm völkermord ist es hier im
eigentlichen sinne noch nicht aber es
ist ein verbotener angriffskrieg sieben
jahren ist verstehen mich in einem punkt
wenn sie sagen sie machen das unter
anderem um deutlich zu machen dass wir
diese brutalen taten alle genau
registrieren unter sachen so ist und
immer auch wieder transportieren die
öffentlichkeit damit vielleicht auch
doch mal irgendetwas bei russischen soll
dazu bleibt sagen das kann ich nicht
mitmachen dann finde ich das ein völlig
tolles ziel ich glaube sie mit dürfen
nicht so sehr bei der öffentlich keine
ahnung am morgen können wir putin vom
gerichtshof glaube doch nicht meinen
guten aber
wozu also welt fern bin ich auch nicht
aber das muss es klar sein dieser mann
ist ein kriegsverbrecher auch noch eine
persönliche frage stellen bevor wir zum
thema dann auch von innen kommen herald
sie haben bei frau maischberger gesagt
die kriegsbilder die ich jetzt von
putins überfall aus der ukraine sind
meine eigenen krieges wieder ihr großes
engagement
dass sie sich jetzt so sehr auch dafür
einsetzen ist es auch aufgrund ihrer
vergangenheit geprägt dass sie das jetzt
so zu ihrer mission machen also ich kann
mich in die leute hinein versetzen ich
habe das die zerstörung dresdens erlebt
in einer nacht bombenangriffe und und
artilleriebeschuss auf während meiner
flucht reise mit meiner mutter also ich
kann euch ich war flüchtling mit zwei
koffern wie ich dir jetzt am bahnhof
hier in berlin sehe also ich kann mich
in diese situation hineinversetzen und
ich kann mich auch an die traumatisieren
automatisierungs situation dieser
menschen hineinversetzen
aber dahinter das ist
das hängt mit meinem mann im leben
zusammen und ich bin ich habe ja die
vorstellung gehabt das kommt nie wieder
verstehen sie immer in der un charta ist
der erste satz wir wollen die mensch von
der geißel des krieges befreit so haben
wir angefangen und nach den beiden
schrecklichen kriegen und in der
allgemeinen erklärung der menschenrechte
steht diese taten des vorigen
jahrhunderts haben das gewissen der
menschheit zutiefst verletzt das
gewissen der menschen hat wird jetzt
wieder zutiefst verletzt der ganzen
menschheit nicht nur nicht nur unsere
aber wir sind in besonderer weise
betroffen und wir kommen ja schritt und
für schritt für schritt immer immer
weiter in den krieg hinein was gestern
der stoltenberg gesagt hat hat mich
nochmal bestätigt das wird eine lange
schmerzhafte verlustreiche sache auch
für uns